cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got this story from the
postmodial breaking Elon Musk fires X
election Integrity team for undermining
election Integrity ah this was just too
good this is big news considering we're
entering the cycle we got a debate
tonight so I figured let's let's jump
into this one Elon Musk announced on
Wednesday that he has cut the Electoral
Integrity team at X in half including
the newly brought on board board head of
the group Aaron rodericks when the news
was reported musk replied Oh you mean
the election Integrity team that was
undermining election Integrity yeah
they're gone is this like wow you
remember when Trump invited Mitt Romney
to have dinner and he said hey mitt
maybe I'll make you Secretary of State
and he just humiliated Mitt Romney at
this dinner there's that picture of
trump grinning like the Cheshire Cat and
Romney kind of you know powered over is
that just what Elon does to these
employees this is oh yeah I'm gonna hire
a bunch of election Integrity be it
sensors and you're fired boom I wonder I
wonder how much of this is 5D chess or I
don't know three how many dimensions are
we getting it's 3D changes yeah right so
Elon Musk goes to war against the ADL
because they're trying to get
advertisers well Elon knows he's got to
push back
how much do you want to bet some of
these advertisers or what companies were
like your platform is undermining
election integrity and then he goes
we're actually hiring an election
Integrity team to make sure that doesn't
happen they went oh okay he brings them
in gets evidence of them screwing with
the election right and then says you're
fired and now he can go here you go we
actually we are so so now Elon can say
no no we are actually upholding election
Integrity we fired these people that
were doing all of these things
maybe maybe I'm overestimating Elon no
no I think Elon if anyone on Earth right
now is playing 5D chess as they talk
about it it's Elon and you can see it in
the way he's handled by the Alex Jones
Band and he hasn't unbanned Alex Jones
account Alex actually is the one who was
like he's playing 5D chess if he unbans
me all the hate of the vehements of the
world will come unto him right now it's
on me we want to leave it on me and Elon
knows that so that's what he's doing is
Alex in the room right now did I I
channel that beast wow so I think Elon
very I mean you've got to be at that
level to be firing Rockets up into space
and working on National Security and
stuff and I mean he's basically
he's veering the momentum of the Ukraine
Russia war in a lot of ways by shutting
down uh starlink over top of Ukraine
last year we finally he didn't shut it
down he never turned it on he never
turned it on yeah so he denied service
to a military to a country during a war
so like this guy's got amazingly
powerful um influence and I think he's
behind the scenes just that they love
him I think a lot of like the arms
manufacturers love him I think that like
yo if we need some a corporatist to be
running the world at least it's Elon
yeah I'm now Pro Elon I was I was always
I was never anti-elon but I was sort of
Elon skeptical because I just wondered
if he was the monorail salesman from The
Simpsons I didn't know if it was all
kind of a con and but well but it it
somewhat is I get but but he he just
keeps winning you know like he whenever
you think well they've got him now kind
of like Trump they've got him now and
then he just pulls a rabbit out of a hat
and and lives to see another day yeah I
think Elon has his agenda he's clearly
working towards a goal he has in mind it
just happens to overlap greatly with the
rest of us yeah and so that works and
then you see some of the stuff that's
going on with you know China and you
know Tesla factories there and you're
like yes Elon has an Elon agenda but it
benefits us so it's like
you know I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
describe Elon as evil I would actually
say we're we're mostly aligned he cares
about free speech he cares about what's
true he wants a platform where you know
Community notes is fact checking the
fake news in the media because he wants
truth but I think his politics
very much aligned with many left-wing
people yeah he talks about it quite a
bit yeah that's true he notes has kind
of ruined satire on the platform though
because it just tells you the joke yeah
yeah it's just a joke explainer at this
point and and I I actually I'm not a I
like Community notes a lot but I got
some criticisms because one thing that
happened was
I put out a tweet
criticizing uh I guess you call it
criticizing but pointing out that the
Rhonda Sanders campaign had used footage
from uh that we so it's complicated but
a lot eliahu reports for timcast however
he owns the the rights after the fact so
we get first rights on all the content
and then he can do whatever selling them
outside the company but we get first
rights to distribute them and so when
the Santa's campaign put out videos with
our video that we had that we had got
first rights on and then put paid for by
the tennis campaign it was literally
just this clip seven seconds long
nothing else there was nothing in it
wasn't an ad it was a video shot by a
lot aliyahu saying he paid for it and
then I asked them I was like hey did you
sell this and he's like no and I'm like
okay well like we didn't sell it to him
yeah so I tweeted we did not sell this
to the tennis campaign or whatever and
what they did was in my tweet pointing
out the clip they sent out to people via
text was was not paid for by the tennis
campaign the DeSantis people used
Community notes to change the context of
what was said to create fake news make
the insinuation was that the screenshot
I had posted was a full-length
advertisement and not a single clip
right right of course my point being hey
they're sharing a clip from our news
channel and then saying paid for by
DeSantis on the video which they did not
do then they put in community notes
advertisements in the political space
must say that they were I'm like it
wasn't an ad so that's right that's my
issue with you know Community because
the community notes are in a way like
democracy which is they're only as good
as the community noters you know it's
only as good as the people and so a lot
of times it's pretty good but then yeah
sometimes people game the system
yeah yeah right just like Wikipedia yeah
yeah I got this one the best community
note I ever saw it says Tim pool is bald
it was in response to help I'm being
Cyber Bullied tweet from last month do
you remember tweeting that out it was
something funny I can't the original
post was lost no I think it's inverted I
think I respected because quarters was
saying like Tim's not even bald and then
the community note
it's only half true because like yes
some some your balls
so you should know a community note on
the community note say a fact jacket
Temple wears a hoodie or a beanie rather
this goes full circle though because the
do so what happened was uh someone
pointed out that one of Twitter's
election Integrity guys was was
insulting me and it was him saying
something like you know if Temple had
hair I don't know I don't remember what
he said someone responded with that
stupid Temple's not even bald then
someone Community noted it saying Temple
is bald and then I quote tweeted the
Twitter Guy saying help help I'm being
separable
that was the best one of the best things
but this guy got fired this is the guy
I'm pretty sure this guy uh Aaron rodder
because that was him he got fired he's
gone and but but I think I think he got
fired because I mean dude you hire a guy
who then immediately goes on an activist
tirade across the board just insulting
people and
your boss is going to be like dude what
are you doing yeah yeah that's I I favor
the 5D chess a little bit here because I
don't know I just get the sense that
Elon knows what's up and he he goes
along and he plays games and he manages
to survive but do you does anyone really
believe that Elon Musk thinks Twitter
needs an election Integrity bizarre or
no way when you put up that job posting
like you have complete control over
election related discourse on one of the
biggest social media platforms what kind
of person does that attract you're
sending in their resume maybe it was a
Honeypot you know Elon Musk is like come
control elections and then he sees who
comes in and he's like I got you
just a big bear trap on the other side
that's right
or but but now you know maybe he's like
look we have all this documentation of
firing these people was upholding
election Integrity I mean he still has
some people there
I think he only cut half of the team
right but he fired he said the election
Integrity team that was undermining
election Integrity they're gone what do
you guys think I guess he's saying
they're they're all gone that's what it
sounds like yeah what do you guys think
about moving shows over to x a lot of
people creators have been doing that
lately does daily wire mess we've tried
Walsh did at one point Walsh had to
because he got booted off of YouTube
whereas he was he was I think it was he
was demonetized then they shut me down
for a week from publishing then they
shut Candice down for a week then they
got me I sort of got out of jail a
little bit and then I think Matt got out
of jail too I don't know about Candace
so it they're just playing games all
it's always constantly moving which
means even if you're up on YouTube this
week we need an alternative long term
and so we've tried X formerly known as
Twitter and it's good we're putting the
shows up there it's nice to have a spot
to do it but you know they just haven't
worked at The Kinks do you guys watch
45-minute shows on right they need a
user friendly yeah it doesn't have like
to the next video it doesn't have to do
related videos do they yeah they they
that rolled out recently the swipe to
the next video and you can now do 2x so
they're remembering it skip ahead skip
back 15 seconds that's a key part of the
player I think Elon needs to do cash
deals Rumble is doing this Rumble is
teaming up with people and saying we
will pay you up front for you to start
building a base on Rumble and it's it's
it's masterful I mean they've got Street
League Skateboarding so for me
skateboarding I'm like they got Street
when I found out they got Street League
I was like whoa that's big mainstream
pop culture stuff exclusive now on
Rumble that's crazy and I watched the
skate video with one of the top Pros in
the world and this is not political
stuff and they got rumble on their wall
in their skate park and I'm like this is
the move I think Elon doing the ad
sharing brilliant very very powerful
move I think the verification checks
people don't understand why this is such
an important thing that Elon Musk did
with uh Twitter blue so 10 years ago all
of these digital websites uh believe
them nameless they would do something
like add right something called ad
rights sales where
a company would go uh like a company
that does clickbait garbage you may have
seen them where it's like 25 pictures of
gross celebrities and each picture is a
new page 800 ads on it so what those
websites would do is all those ad hits
count as ad Impressions and then one
click turns into 25 times 10 ads then
with all those ad hits they sell the
rights to a Big Brand let's you know
call it uh the daily fire or something
yeah just to pick one yeah pick one
random nonsense name but no the daily
wire literally doesn't do this I'm not
trying to I'm saying like a company
would then go to the slim cast something
like that goes to this company and says
we want to own the rights to Those ads
and and claim them and then what happens
is if you get 10 million views they sell
you the rights to those other views and
now slimcast has 80 million views you
then go to your advertise and say the
slimcast network gets 80 million it's
total BS right right what Elon Musk is
doing is going to advertising saying
when someone's season ad and there's a
check mark it is a real human for a
while the concern has been that
advertisers are all being ripped off by
Foreign Farms bot Farms that will make
fake traffic to generate ad sales and
then people are buying ads and they're
wondering why they're not working
it's being ripped away so what this has
actually done is it's made ads more
valuable so it's becoming more expensive
to advertise but the ads have bigger
returns so it's actually keeping
basically what's happening is when a
company would buy ads on these big Tech
platforms half of the money is going to
India or turkey where these Farms
operate out of what with what Elon is
doing is it keeps those ad dollars in
country where there's real people who
are verified
that's why the ad sharing thing is
working it's a good idea long story
short or more to the point I should say
Elon needs to get to the next next phase
where he goes to prominent high profile
individuals and says how much do you
want for your show to be an exclusive X
show yeah we advertise it Time Square
Billboards TV commercials YouTube ads
you name it that's the move they got to
make is there a way that Elon can fix it
I'm glad that they're doing the payouts
even though man I look at some people
they're just like buying cars with their
payouts I'm making pennies over here I
could barely afford a quarter pounder
with cheese with my payouts but it's
okay it's good I'm getting can you have
you said publicly I haven't but I'll
break it here this is breaking news I
hope all the journalists start writing
it up uh my first payout
was right when I signed up was like
eight or nine hundred bucks
and then it dropped to like 200 bucks
and it's like a hundred bucks but I'm
getting more Impressions it's not
impression based it okay yeah the the
money you get from X is based on how
many verified users interact with your
posts this is why you're seeing tons of
people ask questions so this is the
thing because I don't I don't engagement
bait you know I just kind of sometimes I
do accidentally people don't like my
opinions but I don't I you're right the
people who are getting zillion dollar
payouts they all post things like you
know do you hate peanut butter and jelly
why yeah you know it adds value to the
ads but it has decreased the value of a
tweet to the point where my entire
timeline is just people reposting a tick
tock and being like what would you do in
this situation unfollow I can't yeah it
is that's wild you can make more money
but it's decreased the value the actual
human value of the post I think I'm
getting like five grand a month you're
getting five man I gotta get better
tweets what's going on
it's on the internet when the program
first rolled out like a lot of the
tweets about it were in the interest of
transparency
I'm I'm disclosing how much I'm making
off of Twitter ad revenue and it was
these crazy amounts like seventeen
thousand dollars I saw that that looked
insane and I just thought that those
were like paid sponsorships for X right
right I'm getting just shy six grand a
month what yeah I need to get some of
the you got to teach me how to get those
good files tweets well so all lower case
not a lot of like punctuation you don't
need that let me uh things that people
want to correct you know let me let me
let me try and find make an e-course or
like an a paid ebook about
how to farm traffic but there's no a in
the word Farm I'm gonna be the new
Andrew Tate I think you know like how to
get rich quick you're on the road I'm on
the road uh yeah I've got I need a
funnier accent and I have too much hair
but we were talking about your journey
to becoming Michael I'm gonna be a
hustler baby Michael this is what you
need to do okay you see this this is how
you make money on x
that year I I went on mid-journey and I
generated uh Donald Trump Whispering
sweet nothings to a chicken
and I posted it it's got 178 000 views
it's a nice photo so I my mid-journey
journey was mostly centered around uh
pictures of Chris Christie as baked
goods because I really liked the pun of
the croissants and so I've got a a lot
of of like nice flaky crispy faces that
actually get Negative engagement I
actually owe Twitter money at the end of
the month in in all reality though like
uh
I have a tweet I quote tweeted Libby
Emmons it's a it's a NYPD I'll just pull
the pull the Tweet up so you can see the
example so this is like real engagement
right like 2000 replies and it's the
NYPD police spot so it's like news stuff
but you know whatever I don't know I
don't really think about what I tweet I
just kind of Tweet stuff I'm gonna just
maybe I'll just copy your tweets I'm
just gonna take you're gonna tweet
something and then I'll just copy it and
post it and then be rich that's right
that's what I want all right well I I so
the reason why I quote tweet things a
lot is most of my retweets are just so
that I put I'm bookmarking them
basically I'll see a story and I'll be
like oh that's that's big I wanna I
wanna keep that in mind so I'll quote
tweet it like whoa and then I'll share
it yeah but quote tweeting turns a tweet
into your Tweet so it's now your
engagement a retweet it's their
engagement a quote tweet is your
engagement it seems like he's trying to
get rid of quote tweets though or at
least make them less accessible
every time I click on a Tweet now and I
try to look at the quote tweets oh yeah
that's true they're not visible or you
have to like press five different
buttons to get to like View Post
engagement because he probably wants you
to reply like it's all you know when
you're just trying to completely dunk on
someone with facts and logic yeah you
don't reply to them you you quote tweet
them right to send your army of minions
to to mob them yes which is much then
that's more fun the next step is when
you know when Tucker Carlson announced
he was doing that his show on X
everybody assumed it was a cash deal and
then Elon said no no we're not doing
that
but if Elon came out and said like and
like he's wondering why Russell Brand
said all my shows are now on Rumble and
elon's like hey what about us we're
defending you it's like Elon dude
rumble's probably giving him eight
figures or something I don't know what
the deal is but they're they're probably
paying Russell Brand fat stacks to be on
Rumble Elon you can't just be like hey
what about me okay well how much am I
going to pay him they don't have an
exclusive deal with Russell Brando right
because no it still has that like six
million following on YouTube it's a big
deal to walk away from that did you guys
he got demonetized yeah did you follow
up yeah I heard that there's Advertiser
pressure on against Rumble they're like
they're the British Parliament or
something people were trying to aim it
what was that situation Parliament sent
a letter to the rumble Executives and
was like it was worded like emotional
terrorism like we would like to know
what you're doing to protect alleged
victims and you know we're concerned
about protecting the Creator environment
and we're concerned that Russell Brand
is making money off of his content that
has nothing to do with his allegations
I've been concerned about like um
advertisers polling and trying
manipulating social media markets by
being like you know if you if you have
that person on there we're not gonna
We're not gonna give our Ford Automotive
money to YouTube That's So how it's been
so it has been but mine's just trying to
figure out a different way we have
crypto that you can use insights so you
get rewarded for activity inside you get
crypto that you can use in the site to
boost your posts it's kind of like
because so this outside force so like I
hope X I hope he's not too reliant on
advertisers because like he hired Linda
yaccarino and I don't know her but I
I've heard that they're more concerned
about like we don't want crappy posts to
be visible we want the bad things to be
hidden and the good stuff to be seen
because that's what advertisers want
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time